قال وزير الخارجات الروسي ان الحرب ستستمر
طالما كان ذلك يصب في مصلحه واشنطن تطورات
الحرب ايضا كانت محل بحث بين قاده مجلس
اوروبا المجتمعين في ايسلندا من موسكو
تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
ومن مراسلنا عبد الله الشامي وابدا معك
رانيا في اي سياق جاء حديث رئيس عفوا وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
يمكن القول ان هذه التصريحات تاتي في سياق
المبادرات التي بدنا نسمع نسمع عنها
لاسيما المبادره الصينيه للتسويه في
اوكرانيا المبادره الافريقيه المبادره
مبادره امريكا اللاتينيه وما الى ذلك
بالفعل اليوم وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه بروف اشار الى ان الحرب بالمعنى
الضيق بالاشاره للعمليه العسكريه والازمه
الاوكرانيه وفي المعنى الاوسع على ما يبدو
للحرب الغربيه الحرب التي ياخذها الغرب ضد
روسيا نحن نعلم ان روسيا تحدثت على لسان
مختلف المسؤولين ان الحرب يعني ان الغرب
يخوض حرب هجينه على نطاق واسع ضدها هذه
الحرب حسب تعبير اليوم لافروف ستستمر
طالما ذلك يصب في مصلحه الولايات المتحده
بالاشاره الى ان الولايات المتحده بحسب
تصريحات المسؤولين الروس يعني
تحاول اشعال بؤر توتر حول الحدود الروسيه
تحاول استنزاف روسيا في في اوكرانيا
[ضحك]
لن تناسب الغرب الذي اكد مرارا انه متمسك
حصرا بخطه بمقترحات زيلينسكي للتسويه في
اوكرانيا وهذا ما رفضته روسيا سابقا جمله
وتفصيلا لنستمع لما قاله بشان هذه
المقترحات
ذكر وزير الخارجيه البيلاروسي ان هناك
مبادرات اخرى مبادره برازيليه ومبادره
رئيس جنوب افريقيا نحن على استعداد للنظر
في اي من اقتراحاتهم التي تساهم باستقرار
النظام العالمي ولكن حتى الان على عكس
جيراننا الصينيين لم نتلقى شيئا مكتوبا
على الورق لا من البرازيليين ولا من
الافارقه والخطه الوحيده التي يروج لها
الغرب هي خطه زيلينسكي المكونه من عشر
نقاط